لقد تحدثت منذ فترة قصيرة مع
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني السابق بوريس
جونسون، حيث تعامل مع فلاديمير بوتين
على المسرح العالمي على مر السنين، وهو
أيضًا أحد زعماء العالم الأوائل الذين
زاروا الرئيس زيلينسكي في كييف بعد فترة وجيزة من
الغزو الروسي، وقد قام
بالعديد من الزيارات.  رحلات إلى أوكرانيا منذ ذلك الحين،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك يا رئيس الوزراء على
انضمامك إلينا، دعنا ندخل مباشرة في
الأسئلة، شكرًا لك في رواية فلاديمير بوتين
الملتوية والكاذبة تمامًا التي
سمعناها في وقت سابق اليوم، إن الغرب هو الذي
بدأ هذه الحرب ويحاول
تدمير روسيا، كيف  لقد قرأت
طريقة تفكيره في العام الثاني من هذه الحرب،
وأعتقد أنه يائس جدًا وما
قاله مثير للسخرية بالطبع،
لم يكن للغرب أي دور على الإطلاق في بدء هذه
الحرب، لقد كانت حربًا اختيارية
بدأها، لقد كان هجومه الشرير هو الذي
أثار الهجوم.  في أوكرانيا يوم
24 فبراير أه العام الماضي الذي بدأت هذه الحرب
لم تكن أوكرانيا ستنضم إلى حلف شمال الأطلسي أبدًا
في أي نطاق زمني أه واقعي، كان يعلم
أنه فعل ذلك من أجل بلده بشكل أساسي
لأسباب داخلية خاصة به وهو
يريد إعادة بناء الإمبراطورية السوفيتية
يفشل حاليًا في جميع
أهدافه الإستراتيجية الرئيسية حسنًا، إذا فشل في
الحصول على الكيوي، فقد فشل في احتلال خاركيف، كما
فشل في حسن أيضًا، لكن
الحرب مريرة جدًا، مشرقة جدًا،
دموية جدًا، دموية جدًا جدًا، ويحتاج إلى أه،
يجب أن يكون  تم طردهم من
أوكرانيا بأكملها ونحن بحاجة إلى تقديم
المساعدة التي يحتاجونها للأوكرانيين الآن الآن الآن
كلمات قوية جدًا منك أعلم
أنك تعاملت مع بوتين وأتذكر أنه
في بداية هذا
الغزو الوحشي كنت رئيسًا للوزراء
و  لقد قدمت ادعاءً غير عادي
لهيئة الإذاعة البريطانية أن بوتين اقترح مازحًا تقريبًا
أنه يمكن أن يقضي عليك
بصاروخ، تتذكر أن ما
لم يخبرنا به عن ذلك التبادل، نعم
حسنًا، كان هذا في سياق إحدى
المحادثات التي أجريتها مع  فلاديمير
بوتين في الفترة التي سبقت غزوه وما
يحاول فعله هو
إبعادنا وكما فعل في خطابه
اليوم لمحاولة إدخال في
المحادثة باستمرار فكرة
تبادل الصواريخ النووية أه
العواقب غير المتوقعة  أن
يصبح هذا صراعًا نوويًا، إنها
خطوة مهمة جدًا جدًا، لا نسمح له
بذلك ولا نسمح له
بتأطير هذا الصراع كنوع من
المواجهة النووية بين
الناتو المسلح نوويًا وروسيا المسلحة نوويًا
هذا  يدور الفيلم حول غزو
دولة أوروبية بريئة بالوسائل
التقليدية، ونحن الأصدقاء باعتبارنا
مؤيدين لأوكرانيا، وخاصة الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية والمملكة المتحدة والعديد من
الآخرين الذين يساعدون الأوكرانيين في الدفاع عن
أنفسهم بالوسائل التقليدية،
يجب ألا نسمح لبوتين بإسقاط تلك
الأسلحة النووية.  حفرة الأرانب، إذا أردت،
ما مدى قوة رئيس الوزراء
لرئيس الولايات المتحدة في
القيام بهذه الرحلة السرية المحفوفة بالمخاطر إلى كييف
عشية الذكرى السنوية
لبدء الحرب، لقد قمت بنفسك
بنفس الرحلة عدة مرات على ما
أعتقد  إنه لأمر رائع أن جو بايدن
فعل ذلك وأهنئه وأعتقد
أنك تعرف بقدر ما أفهم
الأمر، كانت هذه واحدة من المرات الأولى
في التاريخ التي ذهب فيها رئيس الولايات المتحدة
أه خارج منطقة حيث
أه الطيران الأمريكي  يمكن للقوة ممارسة أه
التحكم المباشر لقد قمت بهذه الرحلة
عدة مرات وأنا أعلم ذلك القطار
جيدًا وفي كل مرة تصطدم فيها
بالنقاط ويكون المسار وعرًا جدًا،
تستمر في التفكير في أنك تتعرض للضرب
أه من قبل أ  لقد كان هذا
بالتأكيد هو ما شعرت به في المرة الأولى التي قمت فيها بذلك،
كان هذا هو الشيء الصحيح تمامًا الذي
قام به الرئيس، وأشيد به
وأعتقد أن خطابه كان ممتازًا
كما تعلمون على الأرجح أن هناك بعض
النقاد هنا في الولايات المتحدة
والهامش أه نقول من اتهم
الرئيس بايدن بإعطاء الأولوية لهذه الحرب
على المشاكل الداخلية والجمهوريين
مثل حاكم فلوريدا رون ديسانتيس
يتساءلون عما يسميه
الشيك الفارغ لأوكرانيا هو أن الشيء الذي
يقلق المملكة المتحدة الآن يقلق
حلفائنا الغربيين
دعني أكون كذلك  من الواضح تمامًا مع
الجميع أن الاستثمار في دعم
الأوكرانيين يمثل اقتصادًا ضخمًا إذا كان
يساعد في حماية سلامنا على
المدى الطويل، وإذا فشلنا في إخراج بوتين
من أوكرانيا، وإذا خسر الأوكرانيون، فسيشكل ذلك
خطرًا على
المنطقة الأمنية الأوروبية الأطلسية بأكملها.  بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة
أه هو كل شيء أكبر
وبالطبع مخاطر القراءة عبر المحيط
الهادئ هي أكبر من خلال
مساعدة الأوكرانيين على الفوز من خلال
العمل الحاسم من خلال منحهم ما
يحتاجون إليه الآن وأنا أتحدث عن المزيد
الدبابات والمزيد من الطائرات والمزيد من
المدفعية بعيدة المدى أعتقد أن
الأوكرانيين قادرون على الفوز وسوف
يكون ذلك ذا أهمية حاسمة
بالنسبة للأمن الغربي ورسالتي إلى
جميع أصدقائي الأمريكيين هي أن هذا
سيوفر لنا جميع الأموال على المدى الطويل
لأنني أعلم أنك تقول أن الوقت قد حان للمملكة
المتحدة للانتقال إلى تشيس وتزويد
أوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتلة إذا اتخذت المملكة المتحدة
هذه الخطوة، فكم من الوقت
ستستغرق فعليًا لإكمال
التدريب على تسليم الطائرة
لإحداث فرق حقيقي
هناك  حسنًا، في ساحة المعركة، ما
الذي كان يحدث لمدة عام
وسنعرف أنه خلال
العام الماضي، اه، استنفدنا في النهاية
جميع الخيارات الأخرى التي
قدمناها للأوكرانيين ما يحتاجون إليه
سواء كان ذلك مناهضًا  - صواريخ الدبابات أو
ما إذا كانت أنظمة الميل العالي
أو ما إذا كانت ليست دبابات، فإننا
نصل دائمًا عاجلاً أم آجلاً إلى
الإجابة الصحيحة ونمنح الأوكرانيين ما
يحتاجون إليه جيدًا إذا كان ذلك عاجلاً أم
آجلاً إذا كان هذا هو الخيار، فلنا
أعطهم ما يحتاجون إليه عاجلاً لأن
هذا هو الشيء الإنساني والرحيم،
إنهاء هذه الحرب في أسرع وقت
ممكن، تقليل سفك الدماء، تقليل
المعاناة، تقليل النفقات،
وأنت تعلم أننا لو بدأنا في منحهم
الطائرات قبل عام لفعلنا ذلك  في هذا
المسار البعيد، لا
أعتقد أن الأمر سيستغرق وقتًا طويلاً لتدريب
الأشخاص على الطيران إما على طائرات تايفون
أو طائرات إف-16 أو غريفين أو أي شيء أو
أي شيء نقرر أننا قادرون على تقديمه
لهم ولكن دعونا نبدأ  استمر في الأمر، وإذا كان
الأمر يتعلق بإرسال أشخاص
يمكنهم القيام بإلكترونيات الطيران وتدريب كبار الموظفين أيضًا على
القيام بذلك،
فلندربهم أيضًا، لذا هل يمكنني أن أفترض يا
رئيس الوزراء أنك تدعو
الرئيس بايدن والولايات المتحدة.  البدء في
توفير طائرات F-16 لأوكرانيا
هو الصحيح وأعتقد أن
منطق ما كنا نفعله هو
الاستمرار في منح الأوكرانيين ما
يحتاجون إليه لحماية أنفسهم لحماية
نصفهم وكسب وطنهم
لحماية عائلاتهم وحماية
بلادهم وطرد بوتين من
المناطق التي غزاها على الأقل
منذ غزو أه يوم 24 فبراير من
العام الماضي ومن وجهة نظري أه الآن
أعتقد أن الأوكرانيين لديهم
حجة أقوى من أي وقت مضى لإخراجه
إلى حدود عام 1991، هذا ما
أه هذا هو أوكرانيا التي
صوت الناس لصالحها في عام 1991، هذه هي
الدولة التي يحق لهم الحصول عليها، أعلم يا
رئيس الوزراء أنك تشارك مخاوف الولايات المتحدة
عندما يتعلق الأمر
بدعم الصين للحرب الروسية، ما الذي غيّر موقف
الصين  الحساب وربما
البدء في تقديم
أسلحة فتاكة إلى روسيا أه حسنًا، انظر أعني
الجميع، الجميع يرون ما
قاله توني بلينكن عنه أه عن الصين، أنا
قلق بشأن ذلك، أعتقد أنه
سيكون من الخطأ جدًا أن يقوم
الصينيون أه بدعم فلاديمير  بوتين
بهذه الطريقة، لماذا تريد بكين الآن أن
تكون ملوثة بما يفعله بوتين،
لماذا يريدون أن
يرتبطوا بهذه العصابات
والمغامرة؟ أعتقد أن ذلك سيكون
كارثة بالنسبة للصين وآمل بشدة
ألا يثبت ذلك.  يكون صحيحًا، ولكن إذا
كان صحيحًا، فإنه يوضح بشكل أكثر وضوحًا
لماذا يجب علينا الآن تسريع دعمنا
لأه أوكرانيا ومضاعفة
إعطائهم ما يحتاجون إليه